welcome to this crash course on bash
scripting throughout this course Herbert
will teach you a wide range of topics
including basic commands writing your
first bash script working with variables
mastering control structures and diving
into powerful text manipulation tools
like awk and said get ready to unlock
the full potential of bash scripting and
enhance your productivity by automating
tasks streamlining processes and making
your workflow more efficient hello
everyone and welcome to this
introduction course to bash shell
scripting this course is aimed at anyone
who is new to Shell scripting people who
want to expand their knowledge or for
those who want to refresh their
knowledge my name is Herbert and I will
be your instructor for this course I've
been in the it sector as a system
engineer since 2009 I've dealt with
multiple systems ranging from Windows
server to Linux servers and in the last
few years I started specializing in
Automation and Development I've been
doing YouTube content creation since
2017 up until now and I've already
created a course on Linux which might be
a good starting point if you're
completely new to Linux I want to learn
more about the basics of the operating
system itself
now what is Bash Bash is short for Born
Again shell it replaced the born shell
in the glue Linux project which was the
default shell for Unix operating systems
a shell is a user interface for ease of
use it makes it easy for the user to
manage the operating system without
knowing all of the inner workings and
complexity of the operating system
itself
now why would you learn bash well the
reason you want to learn bash is because
it's currently the most popular shell
scripting language for the Linux
operating system bash has been around
forever it has been used since the early
days of Linux and it has stood the test
of time ever since it's also included in
Mac OS and in Windows when you're using
the windows subsystem for Linux
now why would you not use bash well even
though bash is considered a programming
language it obviously lacks some
features for example the ability to do
object oriented programming is not
available in bash python would obviously
be the Preferred Choice here if you're
looking to create more advanced scripts
that allow object-oriented programming
speaking of python bash is also more
complex in its syntax When comparing
python syntax to bash one could say that
bash is a lot harder to read and write
not only python is often a better choice
for more advanced scripting newer tools
like ansible also make it a lot easier
for you to manage multiple systems which
is a lot harder to do with bash of
course ansible and python are often
overkill for simple scripts and using
one does not exclude the other bash is
often used in tandem with tools like
ansible or integrated in Python scripts
this is exactly the reason why you
should learn bash just knowing the
basics could mean a big difference in a
lot of situations sometimes the old
trusty tools are still the most reliable
what will you need for this course
I aimed this course at the standard
Windows user so I built the course
around the windows subsystem for Linux
AKA WSL
since we will be only using command line
tools and no GUI WSL seemed like the
obvious choice
and I also have a video explaining how
to install WSL on Windows
if you're running a true Linux distro
even better if you're using a Mac you
can follow along in your terminal window
but first make sure that you have bash
set as your preferred shell
small disclaimer basic Linux knowledge
is required if you're completely new to
Linux or even new to bash I would
suggest you at least follow along with
the Linux guide that I have on my
channel it's going to give you a good
basic understanding of how the Linux
operating system works
before we start with actual scripting
let's first do some basic commands in
the terminal let's look at an example of
two very simple commands to display text
in the command line
the first one is called echo which will
display the text you pass it as an
argument
we will write the command Echo and then
we pass it some text like so
we just type in Echo hello and so we can
dissect this by looking at Echo as the
command and hello as the argument
we will learn more about arguments later
in this course in this case we talk
about a positional argument
now we can see the output that says
hello which is the word we gave it as an
argument
let's try and see how another command
the cat command compares to this the cat
command displays the contents of a file
but right now we don't have one so let's
first create a file with our text editor
Vim in this course we're always going to
be using Vim because it's a good text
editor that comes with almost all Linux
distributions
plus it's actually not that hard to use
if you get the hang of it I myself have
written multiple scripts in bash and
python with Vim so it's definitely a
good text editor unless you want to
start writing some serious scripts or
software in that case a decent Gooby
text editor like vs code atom or Sublime
are better options
let's create a new file with Vim by
typing Vim
textfile.txt and let's write something
in it to write something in Vim press
the I button and you will enter the
insert mode
from this mode you can start writing
text let's write hello world in this
file now we press the escape button and
you will see that the insert mode is now
gone we have exited the insert mode and
we're back into command mode and once
you're back into the regular command
mode you can press the colon W to write
the file and this will make sure the
changes we made are actually done and
saved to the disk and then we can press
Q to exit the file
also to make life simpler we can go into
fim make some changes and combine the
colon W and colon Q to write colon WQ
this will automatically write the file
and quit film at the same time
if you made any changes you don't want
to save you can ignore the changes by
typing colon queue exclamation mark
which will quit Vim while ignoring any
changes made
now that we created our file let's try
to print the contents of the file with
the cat command this command will print
out whatever is in the first positional
argument in our case it's the name of
the file we just created so we just type
in cat text file.txt and we should see
the contents of the file printed here
okay great
we can now print our own text and also
text files to the terminal
this may not sound like much but it's
something that you will use a lot when
writing bash Scripts
so now finally we are going to write a
shell script with the knowledge we just
gathered in the previous section start
off by first opening your film text
editor
and name the text file
shelltest.sh like so Vim space
shelltest.sh
now that we have our text editor opened
let's try another mode of writing text
in Vim the append mode instead of
pressing I on your keyboard press the A
Button this will append your text rather
than insert it with the insert mode you
write the character before the cursor
with the append mode you write the
character after the cursor now in this
case it doesn't matter of course because
it's a new file but I thought I would
mention it anyways since sometimes it
can come in handy let's now start with
our shell script
in Vim write Echo hello world and write
and quit the file by pressing the insert
or append mode writing Echo hello world
then pressing the escape button and then
writing colon WQ
now let's see if we can actually find
the file in here using the ls command
which will list all the files in our
current directory as you can see the
file is there and we can verify the
location by looking at the terminal's
current location over here which says
the tilde symbol and the tilde symbol
indicates that we are in our current
home directory by typing PWD we can
verify that we are indeed in the home
directory PWD stands for print working
directory and this way we can print the
directory that we are currently working
in which is indeed our home directory
now let's run our file by providing the
command line with the command line
interpreter
which is Bash space
shelltest.sh
this will output the command we entered
in the shell script using the bash
interpreter
but when we type in Echo dollar sign
shell we can verify that we are actually
running in a bash shell so should we
really have to specify it
well the short answer is yes just
because we are running in a bash shell
that does not mean that Linux is going
to assume every file we want to run is
also in bash we should always provide an
interpreter for our shell script to use
the correct type of shell
that does not mean however that we
shouldn't make it easier for ourselves
we can actually provide the command line
interpreter in the shell script Itself
by typing it at the top of our script
in our case we have to provide the full
path to the Shell interpreter
let's copy our output from the echo
dollar sign shell command and use it in
our shell script
copy the output by selecting it and
using either Ctrl C or right-clicking
the selection either should work
now let's go back into our shell script
and let's enter the insert mode since we
want to enter all this information in
the beginning of the file press I and
type in pound sign exclamation mark and
then paste in the output of the echo
dollar sign shell command and what we do
here is we provide the shebang so the
pound sign exclamation mark is a way of
telling the shell script which
interpreter to use we follow up the
shebang by providing the full path to
the Shell interpreter and this way the
shell knows which type of shell
interpreter it needs to use we can now
run this file doing period forward slash
shelltest.sh but we will see that
permission is denied and we need to give
the file permission to be executed this
is because in Linux we need to give
files permission to act as an executable
file
let's have a look at this when we type
in LS minus L which is a long format of
the ls command
which is another type of argument we
call a flag so the minus L here is
called a flag we give as an argument to
the ls command we are actually asking
the ls command to provide the long
format which will display some more
information about the files and
directories
we can see in our permissions that we do
not have executable permissions yet if
you want to learn more about the basics
of file permissions you should look at
my Linux for beginners tutorial
let's give our file executable
permissions by typing in chmod or smart
U plus X space shelltest.sh
we want to provide U plus X because this
will give only the owner user permission
to execute the file rather than the
entire group or anybody on the system
it's good to have this discipline baked
into your head although on a development
environment it doesn't really matter
very much
okay now we can finally run our shell
script by typing in Period forward slash
shelltest.sh
and we will see the output on the
terminal now that we finally have the
basics out of the way we can actually
start writing some bash Scripts
to understand a little bit better what
variables do in bash have a look at this
script so in this script you have a
classic example of a copy command where
we copy something from to a location
underneath that we have the same
location paths twice typed out
completely now this is something that
you want to avoid as much as you can
underneath that we have a better option
where we actually Define a location path
in a variable called my location from
now this is quite a long variable name
you could actually just Define something
like loc underscore from which would be
better to make it a little bit shorter
but it's just you know it's just for
demonstration purposes how this would
work so you could understand if you
would have a very long path here you
could have that very long file location
stored in a variable and then you could
actually reuse that variable over and
over again like we did in the example
below that so let's now have a look at
how we can actually use use this in an
example so we can either type our name
like this first name equals let's say
Herbert and that's how we can actually
use these variables by typing like Echo
hello and then typing the variable like
so so that's how it would work like
inline or in the command line itself but
we can actually also just write a script
to demonstrate a little bit better how
variables work so just type in Vim
hello there dot sh
and then we'll do the insert mode with
the shebang forward slash bin forward
slash bash and then over here we'll
Define our first name equals Herbert or
you know your name and then last name
equals lindemann's which is my last name
and I will just do like this Echo
hello dollar sign first name
and then we'll do dollar sign last name
and then we'll exit with WQ and now the
only thing we need to do is smart U plus
X hello there dot sh and now we can run
it and now we can see that our name is
printed out here
just like that
so now we actually type this statically
but we can actually also ask the user
for input like so so let's open a new
shell script with Vim interactive shell
dot sh and we'll do the same we'll
insert then we'll do the shebang bin
Bash
and first of all we'll need to ask the
user like what is your name
so what is your name what is your first
name let's ask and then we'll do a read
statement and we'll read the first name
I will do the same with what is your
last name
and I will read last name
and I will Echo hello
dollar sign first name
space dollar sign last name
and then we'll write in quit
and then we'll do the classic smart U
plus X
and then interactive shell.sh and we'll
run it and now it's going to prompt us
for our first name and for our last name
and then it will just print out our
first and last name like so
we could have the terminal display our
own name or anything else provided in a
positional argument as well but first
what is a positional argument a
positional argument is exactly what it
sounds like we place the argument at a
certain position behind the command or
script we want to run
the positional argument can be in
position 1 2 3 and so forth
the positions are always separated by a
space
when working with positional arguments
you expect arguments to be in a certain
position that is separated by a space
and Counting from one position zero is
reserved for the shell itself
now let's have a look at one of these
positional arguments create a new script
by typing Vim pulse argue.sh and enter
the insert mode again we will have the
script taken our first and last name on
position one and two and have it take
these words as positional arguments
let's just write our shebang and write
our one line of code like so
shebang bin bash Echo hello
dollar sign one dollar sign two
now save the file and close fim change
our permissions and let's run the script
again with the positional arguments dot
forward slash pulse argue.sh Herbert
lindemans or whatever your name is here
and as you can see we get the same
output here with only one line of code
one of the most frequently used features
in bash is piping it makes it very easy
to perform a specific action on the
output of the command
let's say the output of a command is
very long and you wish to filter some
things out piping is going to give you
that option
now how does piping work let's have a
look at an example
let's say we want to look at a specific
directory but we just want to filter out
certain files or subdirectories we could
for example use a command like this
so we're typing LS minus l
forward slash R directory in this case
we're using the bin directory at forward
slash user forward slash bin and then
space and then we type the piping symbol
space grep which is something that we
use to filter out specific words and
then we type in Bash
I will see the output is just the bash
binaries that we can see here rather
than the entire bin directory in this
command we forward the output of the ls
command into the next command with the
pipe symbol
this symbol represents a pipe and this
is what we call piping we literally sent
the output from a command before the
pipe symbol to the command behind the
pipe symbol
grip is just an example there are many
more commands that have very powerful
potential when used with piping
when sending output to a file we have to
use different kinds of symbols than the
pipe symbol instead we use the greater
than and double greater than symbols
these symbols will be used to send the
output from a command to a file this can
have many potential use cases the first
thing that comes to mind is logging
something from your script to a log file
and this is something that you'll
definitely use in real life scenarios
let's see how we can use these symbols
first we catch the output of a simple
Echo command start by typing in Echo
hello world greater than hello.txt this
prints hello world into a file called
hello.txt notice that we put the command
before the greater than symbol and the
name of the text file after the greater
than symbol now we can see if this
worked by typing in cat hello.txt and we
should see the output of the echo
command in here now let's try something
different here type in Echo good day to
you greater than hello.txt and let's see
what's the hello.txt file by typing in
cat hello.txt but what's this the file
was overwritten
we don't have our hello world anymore
well this is because the greater than
symbol always overwrites any existing
file
what we need to have is a proper way to
append text rather than overwrite it
this is where the double greater than
symbol comes in this will append any
output to our destination file rather
than overwrite it let's try it out but
first let's remove that original file
with RM space hello.txt then we use Echo
hello world double greater than symbol
hello.txt and we check if the contents
are indeed correct with cat hello.txc
and indeed the text is there
and once we verified this we send
another output to the file using the
double greater than symbol and type in
Echo good day to you double greater than
hello.txt and we once again verify this
output with cap hello.txt and we should
see both outputs here
now imagine using this in combination
with timestamps to see which command ran
at which time and also some error
handling and we're starting to collect
the tools we need to write a real script
we can also feed input into a command by
reversing the greater than symbol we can
use the lesser than double lesser than
or even triple lesser than symbol to get
input from a file multiple lines of text
or a single string of text
let's first look at the lesser than
operator which will get input from a
text file
we will use the word count command as an
example here because it's one of those
commands that has a use case for these
types of operators let's type in WC
minus W hello.txt to get the word count
but what happens here we get a little
more than we asked for as an output the
WC command by default also shows the
file name which is not what we want
if we just want to get the number of
words we need to feed the WC command and
input from the file with the lesser than
operator rather than the file itself as
a positional argument
this can be done like so WC minus w
space lesser than space hello.txt and
this way we will redirect the file to
the WC command rather than passing it as
a positional argument to the command we
will now get to the second way of
feeding data to a command with the
double lesser than operator this is a
great way to supply multiple lines of
text to a command
when we write the double lesser than
operator we will immediately follow it
up with a word that will open and close
the text we want to input basically we
tell the command line hey wait for this
word and then capture everything I wrote
in between the first and second
occurrence
often people will write eof but you can
write whatever you want
let's have a look at how this would work
so we type in cat space
double lesser than symbol eof now we see
that the command line waits for input so
we can keep writing lines of text here
and let's write some text creating a new
line with the enter key and we'll type
in I will enter write sum enter text
here enter and now we close it with the
first word we Supply it and we type
again eof
and now we should see the text that we
wrote here between the two eof
statements
now last but not least we can also
Supply single strings of text to the
command line
this will be done with you guessed it
the triple lesser than operator let's
have a look at another example of the WC
command we use
by default WC will either read a file or
a command output but not actual strings
supplied as positional arguments
the command either an entire file or the
output of a file with one of the lesser
than operator variations let's see how
we can provide a string to this WC
command so we're typing WC minus W again
space
triple lesser than symbol and then we
open with double quotes hello there word
count and now we close again with double
quotes and we should see the word count
printed here in the terminal this is how
we can feed a string into a command and
take note that the string needs to be in
between double quotes otherwise it will
not work
in bash we have a built-in command
called test that will take in a couple
of arguments and show you if the
expression is true or not for example we
can ask a terminal to show us whether or
not a string of text is equal to another
we can write test followed by the
expression but I prefer using square
brackets let's see how that's done so we
just write open square brackets space
and this is important because you need
the space in between hello space equal
sign space again hello followed by
another space and then closing the
square brackets and this will show no
output but when we do Echo dollar sign
question mark we should see output 0
here because the first string of text is
equal to the second and that would give
us a return value of zero dollar sign
question mark Returns the value of the
exit code of the last executed command
we will learn more about exit codes
later for now it's enough to know that
exit code 0 means that the command was
executed without any issues
another example of this would be
comparing numbers with each other for
example again we open the square
brackets Space 1 equals zero space we
close the square brackets and then we do
Echo dollar sign question mark and this
shows us that the values are not the
same because we get a return code one
but we could also use a different
operator here to make sure that the
values are actually numerical
we could use the minus EQ operator for
this
and we do this with opening the square
brackets 1 minus EQ 1 goes to square
brackets
Echo dot assign question mark this also
shows us the same return value exit code
0 which means that the values do equate
though this would throw an error if you
would use alphabetical characters
instead of numerical ones
now for some more powerful stuff
we can actually use these test
expressions and perform an action on it
let's have a look at this more closely
with an actual script
let's create a login script which will
not really log Us in but it will show us
what is possible with these if alif else
statements
create a new script called if elifls.sh
we type in the shebang
we do if open the square brackets
dollar sign open curly braces one comma
comma close curly bases and I'll explain
to you what this means in just a second
equals
your username
close the square brackets
semicolon then and then we follow up
what we actually want to do here
so we want to Echo oh you're the boss
here welcome
then start a new line
alif open square brackets again dollar
sign curly braces one comma comma curly
braces equals help close the square
brackets
semicolon then
Echo just enter your username the else
Echo I don't know who you are but you're
not the boss of me
and then close it with f i now let me
explain to you what we did here so this
script will take in a positional
argument which is a great way to test
how the if statements will work
we start our if statements with an if
followed by the test expression take
note of the square brackets used in
previous section
we test if the first positional argument
is equal to the value we provide take
note of the double comma and the curly
braces this is called a parameter
expansion and it will allow us to ignore
upper and lower cases When comparing the
two values we then end the test operator
with a semicolon and we follow it up by
then and then beginning a new line and
on this line we type what we actually
want to do with set test expression in
this case we just print something out to
the console telling the user the script
has to recognized the username and that
he is indeed the boss of this system
we can also have a script check for
multiples test expressions
we can Define this with an alif
statement this stands for else if
meaning that else if the previous
statement wasn't true test if this is
true
again start a new line we Define a test
expression that will test if the
positional argument is help and if it is
we display a message that shows us
instructions on how to use the script
being an easy script we want to state
that it isn't so hard to use
maybe a little rude but it's all in good
fun
then if none of these statements are
true finally we have the else statement
this will perform an action if none of
the if or elif statements are true
we can display a message saying that the
username was not detected and that the
system will not be buzzed around by
someone that does not have the correct
username
finally to close our if statements we
end it with f i
this closes the entire block of if lfl's
statements and is required
if alif-l's statements are useful
but you won't use them very often if you
want to check for multiple values for
these kinds of things we use case
statements
first of all what is a case statement
well a case statement performs different
actions depending on which case is true
this means that we can Define multiple
options and if the option matches the
case we will perform an action bound to
that option
let's have a look at how this works in a
real script let's try to recreate our
previous exercise with a case statement
instead of the if alif else statements
create a new file with vim login.sh and
type in the shebang and then we start
our case statement by typing in case
space dollar sign and then the variable
expansion with the curly brackets one
comma comma space in and over here we're
going to do something special we're
going to Define multiple options now
this is something that you could also do
with if statements but I'm just
introducing it here with the case
statements since I thought it would be
interesting to see how it works so we
type in our username space and then the
pipe symbol and over here this is
actually like a separator for multiple
options rather than the pipe symbol that
we saw earlier to pipe things through to
different commands in a case statement
it serves a different function over here
it serves as a separator for multiple
options
so username space pipe symbol space and
then another username for example the
administrator and then we close the
bracket
and then we Define what we want to say
or do here so you want to say something
like uh oh you're the boss here welcome
again like we did in the previous
exercise
and then we close this option with
double
semicolons then we Define another option
here for example help like we did in the
previous exercise
we copy the same Echo command now we
close that option with double semicolons
and then what we do here is we Define
this star symbol or asterisk or whatever
you want to call it and this is the
catch all option that we're going to
Define
and the catch all option is like the
default option when none of the options
are true or when no options are given
and then we Define hello there but
you're not the boss of me please enter a
valid username and then we close that
option with double semicolons and then
close that with esac so it's case just
reversed so again like I said before
notice that we have two options in one
line using the pipe symbol again when we
use the pipe symbol in one of the case
statement options we can use it to have
multiple values to test for we Define
our option for help
also Define a catch all our default
option and this is equal to like the
else statement like we saw earlier
meaning that if none of the options are
equal to the input we will perform a
specific action and now we can run our
script and get the results that we
expect
before we get into looping we need to
First extend our knowledge about
variables
we can actually assign multiple values
to one variable collected in a list we
call these kinds of variable lists
arrays
let's see how we can actually create
this in the command line in the command
line type my first list equals
Open brackets 1 Space 2 Space 3 Space 4
space 5 close the brackets
take note of how we start the array with
Open brackets use a space as a separator
for each item and close the array with
the closing bracket
now let's see what the output is when we
try to print this array
just type in Echo and then just like we
would with any other variable
space
dollar sign my first list
and now we will see that the output is
just the first element and this is of
course not what we want to Echo the
entire list we need to specify it like
this
Echo dollar sign
open curly braces my first list
square brackets at symbol close the
square brackets close the curly braces
and this will print out everything in
the list but we can also Define which
item we want to print like this
Echo space dollar sign curly braces my
first list
square brackets and then over here we'll
just type in 0 which is the Index close
square brackets close the curly braces
and this will print out the first item
in the array because we Define the index
in between the square brackets and
because in bash the first item in the
array always has index 0 counting
upwards we will see the first item in
the array but let's say we want to do
something else with all these items in
the array we can do this with a for Loop
now that we have created our array we
want to Loop over the items in it and do
something using a for Loop in our
example we will count the length of each
word in the array by piping the item
output using Echo to the WC command
don't forget to specify the minus n flag
in our Echo command because otherwise it
would also count the new line characters
type in the command line for space item
space in
dollar sign curly braces my first list
square brackets at square brackets curly
braces semicolon space do space Echo
space minus n space dollar sign item
space pipe symbol space WC space minus c
semicolon space done
take note of how we write the for Loop
here we first Define the variable item
which will represent each item in the
array during the loop then we Define the
iterable which is our array
and what shall we actually Define it in
our for Loop we encapsulated in our
curly brackets and add the square
brackets add square brackets after it to
make sure we Loop over the entire array
then we follow it up with a semicolon
space then we type in do and then we
type in what we actually want to perform
here so we'll type in do Echo minus n as
I said the minus n is just a flag for
the echo command to ignore all the new
line characters then space dollar sign
item because the dollar sign item will
represent one of the items that we are
currently looping over space and then
the pipe symbol WC minus C and then we
do again semicolon and then we type in
done
to understand why we need functions in a
bash script we should first consider
this
in some scenarios we have a lot of
repeated code we might want to do a
specific set of commands in a certain
order or we want to run data through a
set of if else statements multiple times
for these scenarios we create functions
these functions are like little programs
within your script that you can run from
within your script
it makes it so that you can make your
code reusable very powerful stuff
because we can save so much time and
lines of code
let's write our first function in bash
let's open up a new file called first
function.sh I will type in the shebang
and then a new line will type in the
name of the function I will just call
this show uptime and then we open and
close the brackets and then we open the
curly brackets we'll type in up equals
dollar sign Open brackets uptime minus P
pipe cut minus C4 minus and then close
the brackets we'll type in since equals
dollar sign Open brackets uptime minus s
close the brackets and again if I'm
going a little bit too fast for you you
can pause the video and I'm gonna go
over what we actually did here I'm going
to dissect everything we did here in
just a second I did a new line again cat
and then we'll use the double lesser
than symbol eof and we'll type a new
line and we'll just create something
pretty here a few dashes I will type in
this machine has been up for dollar sign
curly braces up curly braces it has been
running since since dollar sign curly
brackets since curly braces then a new
line of then we do a new line of dashes
then we end our statement with eof
close the curly brackets and then we
just type in show uptime so let's
dissect this again
first we Define the name of the function
followed by open and close brackets
followed by the curly brackets to Define
what our function does we enter all the
things it needs to do in between the
curly brackets in our case we will show
the uptime of the machine watch how we
catch the output of a command into a
variable using the dollar sign brackets
notation then we do this again in the
next variable we Define the variable in
the same way but we use different flags
for the uptime command and store that
output in the since variable and we can
now create a nice output using these
variables using the cat command and the
redirection we learned earlier in the
course we end by closing the curly
brackets and then we call the function
by just typing it anywhere in the script
as long as it's typed under the function
it's fine because we need to make sure
that the function first is defined
when we Define a variable in our
function it's available to the entire
script by default this might seem okay
but it can actually cause trouble when
you write bigger Scripts
we want to define the variables inside
our functions as local variables so that
they are only available to our function
and not to the entire script
this way we will avoid accidentally
overwriting Global variables which might
cause issues when we are using functions
that share these variable names let's
have a look at what happens when we
don't use local variables
so let's define our variables named up
equals before since equals function and
then we'll just print those out before
we Define the function so we'll just
Echo up an echo since and then now we
will Define the show uptime function
again and we will leave it the way it is
and then Echo up and Echo since and
let's run it and in this example we can
see that the variables are indeed
globally available which is not what we
wanted we'll see also that they are
globally available but we have actually
overwritten the variables that were
defined before the function and then the
function was actually reassigning those
variables because they are not assigned
as local variables let's fix that so the
only thing we need to do to fix it
really is just add local before we
Define the variable in our function so
instead of just writing up and since
equals the commands that we want to use
before the up we'll just enter local
space and then the same goes for since
we'll Define local space and when we run
this we can now see that our variables
are available to the scope of our
function but the global variable is not
overwritten
just like our entire bash script can
have a positional argument so can our
function let's have a look at an example
create a new script called function
pulse argue.sh I will write the shebang
and that will open our
function with the function name open the
brackets open the curly brackets and
then we'll write Echo hello dollar sign
one
and then close the curly brackets and
then we'll write the function name space
and then whatever you want to write here
we'll write our own name so we can write
out whatever set of characters we want
but in this case we wrote Our Own Name
we could even go as far as to pass
positional arguments of the entire
script to the positional argument of the
function and of course functions can
also take in multiple positional
arguments so lots of stuff is possible
here
let's open up the previous file
underneath the echo statement we'll type
an if statement and then we'll say if
dollar sign curly braces 1 comma comma
equals and then your username which in
my case is Herbert close the brackets
semicolon then return zero else
we will return one
and I will close the if statement then
also over here we'll remove this static
name and change it to a positional
argument one and then also if dollar
sign question mark equals one and close
square brackets semicolon then Echo and
then it will write someone unknown
called the function and then we'll close
the if statement and we're writing quits
and let's now try to run this
with tests for example it'll say hello
test but then you'll see that it also
says that someone unknown requested the
function
awk is one of the most useful tools in
the bash arsenal we use awk to filter
file contents or the output of a command
in such a way that we can print out the
most essential parts and get the output
the way we like it to use awk we can
either filter parts of a file or we can
filter parts of a command output by
piping that output into awk let's have a
look at how we can filter through a
simple text file with awk we first
create a test file which contains three
words separated by a space once we
created that file we can put awk to work
type in awk single quote open the curly
brackets print dollar sign 1 close curly
brackets single quotes space the name of
our test file we will see that the
dollar sign one acts as a placeholder
for the first item in the text file we
could also get the second word that
comes after the first word always
separated by space by typing in awk
single quotes curly braces print dollar
sign two close curly braces single quote
and again our test file now that we get
the idea of awk in its default mode
which is using a space character as a
separator we can move on to changing it
into other characters such as a Kawa
let's create a CSV file and add three
values in it again separated by a comma
this time now we can use awk again to
split the values in the CSV file by
adding the minus capital F flag and
specifying the split character
afterwards like this awk minus capital F
comma space open the single quotes
open the curly braces print data sign
one close the curly braces single quote
test csv.csv and now we will see that
the output is also the same as in our
previous examples but we will see that
awk actually used the comma as a
separator character and last but not
least we can also pipe commands into awk
like so type in Echo just get this word
colon hello and now we pipe into awk and
we'll print out number five because this
is the fifth word separated by space and
I will see that the word hello will be
printed out or we can also split this at
the colon symbol like so
Echo just get this word colon hello pipe
into awk and then we specify the minus F
we follow it up with a colon and then
print dollar sign 2 and I will still
have to cut off the first character
which is a space and that will get the
same results as well and that's just the
beginning of course there's a lot more
possible with awk so if you want to
practice you can try using it more often
in your scripts it really pays off to
know this well because you'll do a lot
of output filtering and reformatting in
Bash
there will come a time where you want to
change certain values in text files and
that's where SED or set comes in set is
a command line tool that would allow you
to modify values in a text file using
regular expressions
let's have a look at an example on how
to use SED or set to replace values in a
text file
create a text file called
settest.txt and let's write down some
text here now we will replace the word
fly with Grasshopper just for
demonstration purposes
so we type in set single quotes s
forward slash fly forward slash
grasshopper forward slash g single
quotes and then the name of our text
file which is settest.txt now the
structure of this command is a little
bit daunting but let's break it down
first we start off with the set command
we open the single quotes and start our
regular expression first we enter the
mode we want to use which is s for
substitute meaning we want to substitute
the next word behind the forward slash
with the word after the second forward
slash which is the first one is fly and
then the second one is grasshopper then
after the last we provide the G which
means that we want to do this globally G
stands for globally and globally means
that we want to do this across the
entire text file which means that we
want to change every occurrence we close
it with another single quote and we put
the text file we want to change behind
the entire command let's say we want to
keep the original in a backup file we
can do this by adding the minus I flag
to the command like so so we just do the
same thing we'll just do set minus I dot
original and then we enter the exact
same command we just provided earlier we
can see here that we use the minus I
flag but we don't put a space behind it
instead we write the entire suffix
behind T minus I flag this will create a
backup file which contains the original
content of the file we just changed with
the set command but the original file
will have the changes we desired just
like with awk this is a basic
introduction to set and there will be so
much more to it but as with all things
in it you need to discover this by
yourself by trying it out as much as you
can well this brings us to the end of
the course